hamdullah we made it to London the UK
and it's really cool the customs officer
he actually was a fan of the show he
watches the Dean show here in London
they cool so we go from from right to
left you guys know our brother Muhammad
good job this is we're in the Salaam
Studios Mahmood
Mahmood but then we have our brother
Muhammad and you know our brother Ali
Dawa you know our brother
Navid for Massino nevide Adi Adi yeah so
basically mama that was a football fan
and one of the players name is sunder so
he need me name is na but what it means
is all you know when the movie finishes
it says the end yeah my name is
basically Shawna Eddie and maybe that's
the reason why I start learning from and
[Laughter]
reaction video with our brothers here
Salam Salam peace sharing affection love
and mercy now in here ended hamdulillah
but it's all off we don't see each other
again inshallah Jenna GPS GPS today
there you go how's that huh let's go you
guys know this guy's my tag-team partner
now so now I tagged him now he's got to
come back Chicago and tag me
comes to New York or something or go to
California no he's talking me Bosnia
how's that huh Bosnia I've heard great
things about Bosnia yeah honestly
everyone who's ever been to Bosnia has
only good things to say about it how you
like that huh guys if you want to meet
up in Bosnia let us know there you go
what do you think about that we're just
coming from where are we coming from
East London
thank you my brother thanked me and we
are arriving at the Islam channel hum
didn't I alaikum Salam Horace's how are
you say hello today to the D show hello
it to the Deen show so slow tour of the
Islam channel in the UK reception there
and this is our guests coffee place when
we have networking and so on coming here
over there this is our working area so
we're the producers such as free
breakfast
just somebody this is our
post-production and here you have the
most dedicated people so long it will
stay late
this is where you can watch the detail
the motivational airs on
[Music]
what's up guys how you doing we're about
to go live on the Dean show on Aslam
channel and make sure you're tuning in
the Dean show is on Islam channel if
you're in the UK it's over in 100
countries make sure you're checking it
out just finished the interview was
launched and I met this very nice
brother who with his wife sister his
sister here both of them and you guys
both wrote this book and it's a
wonderful project and it's called
A to Z sign language Islamic signs
let's just go real quick and just come
on show me the one couple signs in there
so sign like Allah so you do index
finger went to this a lot that's it just
pointing out for the signs then go
bismillah stuff minute pointing to Allah
so bismillah bismillah and sign language
point out bismillah
we've got knowledge thumbs up point to
the head
so knowledge thumbs up what the head
knowledge in sign language we've Koran
Janissary yes
and they like to refer one more one more
randomly suna you wanna show that all
right beautiful and working get work if
people get this book if they wanted to
purchase it
WWE Ness mean calm this is a great
effort man thank you guys
assalamualaikum guys so we're back in
what part of London is this now holiday
right now we're in West London in around
Wembley area and we finished up Khalid
we just met he works at the Islam
channel for what like he said ten years
thirteen thirteen years now and he said
something that's really fascinating and
we talked about that you know that he's
an involved in the in this effort giving
back and and go ahead and you talked
about the contribution a contribution
giving you that rewarding feeling
otherwise you'd be yea hamdullah I mean
the reason like what keeps me going on
Islam China is just the the reward for
of it like for example I mean when I see
people take their Shahada on the channel
people call in non-muslim take the
Shahada that's the reward that's the
feeling that you can never you know
achieve to be honest all people that
call in that they never used to practice
in the hamdullah now because of watching
Islam Channel now they're there
practicing practicing so that kind of
keeps me going on it's lunch and even
though I have my other businesses but
then the fact that you know the reward
feeling which I get you know the
motivation from Islam channel that
cannot be bought anywhere else hence I'm
still here hamdullah and inshallah be
there for many years to come and that's
what we said that if everybody does
their small part imagine that all the
Muslim 1.7 billion imagine everyone put
a little bit more F
towards the Dean sharing the Dean what
kind of impact do you think that would
have huh
surely that would have been a huge
impact because obviously the end of the
day we're all gonna go for what the
legacy of what we have contributed back
to the religion that is the most
important part because obviously
dinya you know you can change denier
forever but we need to think you know
about our at the dinner which is
Hereafter so each other every one of us
has to do our parts and while we here
while we have the time or we can do it
so you know that voice would be everyone
has to do their part inshallah give
their bits of a tower and then revive
the Sun and drive the Dean those are
those gems of wisdom that we're getting
cool action by the way very coagulant is
it here in London
Dean show will see the funeral we
finally made it we get a proper hug in
Slough rather look forward to seeing me
again thank you brother
alright guys I'm hungry now we had a
we started off early morning and got an
early morning flight
we started off early where any very late
but a hundred la we're back
still in London and we're looking for
those gems sharing those uh in some very
wonderful interesting people keep
staying tuned in slowly